foreign
and welcome to Rotten Tomatoes countdown
we all know that fans sometimes love to
hate their comic book movies but more
importantly fans also love to love their
comic book movies too
how about another joke Marie no I think
we've had a not be a joke this is our
countdown a fan favorite DC EU movies by
audience score and it's gonna be super
[Music]
starting with number 10 the Batman
with many fans looking for something new
after the Ben Affleck era of Batman in
came this movie directed by Matt Reeves
and with Robert Pattinson taking over
the mantle of Batman where we find him
in just his second year of fighting
crime along with Pattinson the rest of
the film's star-studded cast helped lure
fans into this new look Gotham 2 with
names like Zoe Kravitz Paul Dano Jeffrey
Wright and Colin Farrell the Batman is
certified fresh to go along with its
strong audience for
number nine DC League of Super Pets
they brought some animated fun to the
dceu in 2022. hoping to get a new
generation of fans excited about the
brand with this long-awaited project now
Dwayne Johnson provides a voice of
Superman's dog crypto headlining a who's
who voice cast that includes names like
Kevin Hart Kate McKinnon John Krasinski
Diego Luna Natasha Leone and the Keanu
Reeves and the strong audience score for
League of Super Pets comes with the
common praise that it's quote a cute and
colorful good time for older kids and
their parents
of course you can I mean what's the
worst that could happen I could hurt
someone
or they could hurt me or maybe me
freezing like this is the word
[Music]
number eight Batman mask of the Phantasm
this animated movie came out in 1993 and
it's based on the popular Batman the
Animated Series which launched the year
before the now long time voice of Bruce
Wayne Batman Kevin Conroy reprized his
role from the series along with Mark
Hamill as the Joker which I loved
because Kevin Conroy will always be my
Batman the film also introduced the
character of Andrea Beaumont AKA
Phantasm voiced By Dana Delany as Andrea
and Stacy Keach as the electronically
modified voice of Phantasm crazy
[Music]
stay away this is not your fight
number seven Black Adam
this film stars Dwayne The Rock Johnson
who after much prodding from fans and
plenty of work on his end was finally
able to make the movie happen in it the
anti-hero Black Adam emerges after 5 000
years with his unique form of justice
for the modern world now along with the
rock making his live-action entrance
into the dceu Black Adam also introduced
talk man played by Alice Hodge and
Cyclone played by quintessa Swindell and
while critics didn't love it and the box
office numbers could barely recruit the
film's budget an 88 audience score shows
that fans are loving the character
laughs
number six Joker
featuring an oscar-winning performance
from Joaquin Phoenix not to mention
bafta Critics Choice sag Golden Globe
and other Awards this film follows a
failed comedian named Arthur Fleck as he
seeks connection on the streets of
Gotham City Joker is fresh on the Tomato
Meter and has a strong audience score of
88 with Phoenix being a big reason one
audience review said that he quote
transforms into a new original take on
the Joker adding another great addition
to probably the best arch villain icon
[Music]
thank you number five V for Vendetta
released in 2006 this film is based on
the 1988 DC vertical Comics limited
series of the same name with the
screenplay being written by sisters Lana
and Lily Wachowski from The Matrix
movies V for Vendetta marked the
directorial debut for James mctee who
actually first met this film star
Natalie Portman during the making of
Star Wars Episode 2 attack of the Clones
and speaking of fan favorite Portman she
won the lead role of Evie over names
like Bryce Dallas Howard Scarlett
Johansson and Kira Knightley which
really just meant that she happily got
to buzz her hair on film which took
three cameras to shoot and for obvious
reasons just one take
the only verdict is Vengeance a vendetta
held as a votive not in vain for the
value and veracity of such shall one day
vindicate the Vigilant and the virtuous
Number Four The Dark Knight Rises
the smell marks the final installment in
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
after Batman Begins and The Dark Knight
now it takes place eight years after the
events of the latter and introduces a
villain Bane played by Tom Hardy the
certified fresh flick has an audience
score at 90 percent with one audience
review saying that quote Nolan's epic
Trilogy concludes in glorious fashion
and gives us a thought-provoking and
suitably satisfying conclusion to an
epic Saga well said
number three Zack Snyder's Justice
League
this is the director's cut of the 2017
film Justice League as director Zack
Snyder intended it now he actually
stepped down during post-production
following the death of his daughter and
Joss Whedon was hired to finish that
film and what began as a social media
pipe dream ended up becoming a movement
to release this version with an online
petition that gained more than a hundred
and eighty thousand signatures along
with public support from Justice League
stars like Ben Affleck galvado and Jason
Momoa coming as a four-hour film instead
of the ones considered mini-series
format this updated version came with a
70 million dollar price tag for visual
effects score editing and new filming
but the improvements in both Tomato
Meter and audience scores over the first
one is something you just can't put a
price on am I right
[Music]
thank you
number two Batman Begins
this served as a reboot for the Batman
film series coming less than a decade
after one Mr George Clooney donned the
cape and Batman and Robin this time
Christian Bale took over the mantle
Bruce Wayne emerging from a list of
names that included Henry Cavill Billy
crude up Jake Gyllenhaal Heath Ledger
and Josh Hartnett Bale ended up taking
over the role and ran with it gaining a
hundred pounds of muscle and losing his
voice three times for the role on his
way to becoming a clear fan favorite
Batman actor and the anchor of a very
popular trilogy
oh man
[Music]
and of course number one The Dark Knight
while the other two films in Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy are also on
this list this one sits at the top for
one reason and one reason only Heath
Ledger as the Joker Heath actually
passed away a few months after he
completed filming and six months before
the movie's release but was posthumously
awarded a best supporting actor Oscar
for his performance in fact after
becoming the highest grossing film of
the year with over a billion dollars
earned plus it was selected for
preservation in the National film
registry as just the second superhero
film to earn the honor after 1978
Superman and as you now know this
certified fresh film also has the
highest audience score in all the dceu
I believe whatever doesn't kill you
simply makes you
stranger
all right my friends that's our list of
fan favorite DC EU movies but hey you
are the fan here so please let us know
if you have any disagreements with your
fellow audience members and seriously go
check out the animated Batman movies if
you haven't already until next time I am
your host Nas Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]